in the Meg Statham played Jonas Taylor a
scorned X rescue diver with a personal
Vendetta against the mysterious massive
underwater Beast that only he believes
is real it's like Jaws on steroids while
the film's enormous money there is only
a product of CGI and bad dreams don't
get it twisted Statham probably would
have hopped in the water even if the
thing was real in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly The Notorious
English Daredevil recorder time when he
went diving with bull sharks and Fiji
admitting that it wasn't ordeal being
inches away from a swarm of the large
toothy fish saying all of the fear or
the perceived fear is done in your own
head before you get down there with them
so once you're swimming down there with
all the other divers it's phenomenal
it's one of the greatest experiences you
could have for me anyway swimming in
shark infested waters is apparently just
another relaxing day in the life of
Jason Statham